.
* Anschwellende,
erwartungsvolle Musik *
Alle sagen immer, ich sei
so sicher in meinen Entscheidungen.
Sie sagen sogar, ich schüttle sie
aus dem Ärmel. Das ist Quatsch.
Ich habe
bei jeder Entscheidung Zweifel -
v.a. hinterher.
Meistens denke ich: "Das muss ich
machen. Jetzt mache ich das."
"Schluss, es gibt nichts anderes."
Und dann kommt das Nachdenken,
das Hinterherdenken.
Dann wird es unschön.
Das ist das Wesen
intuitiver Menschen.
Sie werden später
von solchen Dingen geplagt.
Das muss man durchstehen.
Die Einsamkeit,
die man in der Führung hat,
muss man ertragen können.
* Dunkle, spannungsvolle Klänge *
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Bravo, super!
- (Blocher) Guten Appetit.
Welcome.
* Lachen *
Guten Appetit.
Euch geht es gut hier, was?
Schön, dass Sie hier sind. Gut.
Guten Tag.
Ich kann mich hierhin setzen.
Ah, soll ich zu dir kommen?
Gut, nimm die Mappe.
Christoph Blocher
referiert vor begeisterten Anhängern
über die Schweiz und die EU -
sein Lieblingsthema.
Es sind ganz schön viele Leute hier.
- Ja, nicht wahr?- Ja.
Schön.- Es ist schön
in Reinach, nicht wahr?- Ja.
Auf der Rückseite sind die Strophen.
Vielen Dank.
Wenn ich die Möglichkeit dazu
hätte - Bolliger ist mein Name -,
würde ich Sie 20-mal klonen.
So? Ja, gut.
* Er lacht. *
* Applaus *
Liebe Miteidgenossen
und Miteidgenossinnen,
auf unserem Gebiet
wollen wir selbst bestimmen.
Ob wir bestimmen oder ein anderer -
dafür gibt es nur ein Wort:
Widerstand.
Es gab schon mal eine Situation,
in der man die Schweiz
in die EU führen wollte.
Das war die wichtigste Abstimmung
des letzten Jahrhunderts:
die Abstimmung über
den Europäischen Wirtschaftsraum.
Es klang auch so harmlos:
"Das ist noch kein EU-Beitritt."
Herr Ogi sagte jeweils: "Das ist
ein Trainingslager für die EU."
Bevor man ins Paradies darf,
muss man trainieren.
* Applaus *
Und was passierte damals?
Die ganze Classe politique -
der Bundesrat,
fast das ganze Parlament,
die Kantonsregierungen
und praktisch sämtliche
Schweizer Zeitungen sagten:
"Wir müssen beitreten. Wir
verrecken, wenn wir es nicht tun."
"Die Schweiz geht unter,
wenn sie nicht beitritt."
Die armen Journalisten
schrieben sich die Finger wund
wegen dieses Blödsinns,
wegen dieser Fehlprognose.
Aber das Schweizer Volk
hatte die Kraft, zu sagen:
"Nein. Widerstand.
Wir bleiben selbstständig."
(Mann) Jawohl. Bravo.
* Applaus *
Herzlichen Dank.
Meine Frau ist halt etwas schüch-
tern. Sie bekam diese Blumen.
* Lachen, Applaus *
Das ist wirklich wichtig.
An einer solchen Feier
stand mal jemand auf und fragte:
"Herr Blocher, woher
haben Sie eigentlich diese Kraft?"
Ich sagte: "Ich habe noch eine Frau
im Rücken, die darauf achtet,
dass ich keinen Blödsinn erzähle."
Auf der Heimfahrt
spricht sie dann schon darüber.
* Lachen *
Danach stand eine andere Frau auf -
also, sie sah hässlich aus
und ...
* Lachen *
Sie sagte:
"Das ist typisch für Sie."
"Die Frau steht natürlich
hinter Ihnen und nicht vor Ihnen."
Ich sagte: "Wenn ich Sie geheiratet
hätte, wären Sie vorn gestanden."
"Aber das wäre
auch nichts geworden."
* Lachen, Applaus *
Herr Blocher, vielen Dank.
- Gern geschehen.
Sie sprachen
frisch von der Leber weg.
Ja, das ist wichtig.
- Herzlichen Dank. Es war super.
Ich bin einfach ein grosser Fan
von Ihnen - wirklich.
Sie sprachen mir aus dem Herzen.
- Gut, das freut mich.
Ich freue mich so,
Sie mal in echt zu sehen.
So? Gut, gut.
# (Alle) Trittst im Morgenrot daher,
# seh' ich dich im Strahlenmeer ...
Seit 1992
ist Christoph Blocher ein Idol:
Er gewinnt damals eine der
wichtigsten Abstimmungen der Schweiz
und verhindert so
die enge Anbindung an die EU.
# (Alle) Wenn der Alpenfirn
sich rötet,
# betet, freie Schweizer ...
Christoph Blocher.
# ... betet.
Wir treffen ihn mehrmals
für ausführliche Interviews.
* Dunkle, spannungsvolle Klänge *
Er führt uns zuerst
in seine Kunstsammlung.
V.a. der Berner Maler Albert Anker
fasziniert ihn.
(Lachend) Hier herrscht
eine vorübergehende Unordnung.
Dies sind Bilder,
die an Ausstellungen gingen,
zurückkamen und
noch nicht an Ort und Stelle sind.
Aber was hier an den Wänden hängt,
ist alles von Albert Anker.
# Dunkle, schwermütige Klänge *
Vielleicht beginnen wir
zuerst hier drüben.
Das sind Hodler-Bilder,
aber hier ...
Hier hinten haben wir noch ...
Hier sehen Sie Ankers Hauptwerk.
Dies ist ein besonderes
schönes Bild von Anker.
Das ist "Der Schulspaziergang".
Seit mehr als 20 Jahren habe ich
dieses Bild beim Essen vor mir.
Ich habe es noch nie ausgewechselt.
Es ist jeden Tag faszinierend.
Keines dieser Kinder
ragt über den Horizont hinaus.
Aber eine Person ragt über
den Horizont in den Himmel hinaus:
die Lehrerin.
Mit der Zeit merkt man,
dass das Ganze
von diesem bis zu diesem Scheitel
und von hier
bis zu den hintersten Scheiteln
wie ein Dach wirkt.
Die Kinder stehen
unter dem Dach der Lehrerin.
Er war ein Mensch, der anerkannte,
dass es noch etwas Höheres gibt
als nur den Menschen.
Wie ist das bei Ihnen?
Sind Sie auch religiös?- Nein.
Aber ich muss aufpassen,
religiös ist ein gefährliches Wort.
Aber auch ich glaube,
dass es eine höhere Macht gibt.
Und auch ich bin der Meinung -
das gaben wir
auch an unsere Kinder weiter -
dass wir nicht verdammt sind.
Wir stehen alle unter der Vorsehung
und der Gnade Gottes.
Sonst wären wir gar nichts. Wir
wären nicht da und könnten nichts.
Alles, was wir tun,
ist im Grund gegeben.
Das gilt für alle Menschen,
auch für unsere Gegner.
Aber Sie haben
einiges erreicht in Ihrem Leben.
Sie trafen Entscheidungen.
Das war nicht alles Zufall.
Mir sind gewisse Dinge gelungen.
Ich sage es immer so:
Sie sind mir gelungen.
Sie hätten ja
auch missglücken können.
Wenn man etwas getan hat,
das einem gelungen ist,
sollte man sich nicht
zu sehr selbst loben.
Man sollte sagen:
"Es ist mir gelungen."
Und ich weiss noch etwas anderes:
Ich bin ja ein intuitiver Mensch.
Ich habe mich einfach entschieden,
gewisse Dinge zu tun.
Selbst wenn ein Mensch sagt:
"Das habe ich getan",
ist vieles einfach gegeben.
* Getragene Musik *
* Laufschritte *
"Zweiter Bundesratssitz gefordert,
Blocher vorgeschlagen."
Auf der Frontseite der "NZZ"?
- Jawohl.
War dieser Coup
von langer Hand vorbereitet?
Das ist eine Strategie.
Wir sind ja verpflichtet,
Strategien zu machen.
Gestern staunte ich,
dass mit Ausnahme der SVP
keine Partei
eine Strategie auf den Tisch legte.
* Spannungsvolle, trommelnde Klänge *
* Eine Glocke klingelt. *
Gewählt ist mit 121 Stimmen ...
- ... est elu avec 121 voix ...
... Herr Nationalrat
Christoph Blocher.
* Jubel *
Ich tue, was ich kann,
und hoffe, Gott hilft uns,
dass es gut herauskommt.
Ich schwöre es.
- (Mehrere) Ich schwöre es.
Félicitations.
- Danke.
Alles Gute für die Zukunft.
- Moritz.
Christoph, ich gratuliere dir.
(Mann) S'il vous plaît.
Der neu gewählte Bundesrat verkauft
sein Unternehmen an seine Kinder:
* Jubel, Applaus *
Liebe Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeiter,
ich darf Sie nur noch
ein paar Tage lang so ansprechen.
Am 31. Dezember
muss ich Schluss machen.
Das lest ihr täglich in der Zeitung.
Man befürchtet, ich könne mich
nicht von euch trennen.
Seien Sie willkommen.
Das ist, äh ...
Das ist doch schön, nicht wahr?
Es ist gut geworden.
- Sehr schön.
Wollen Sie erzählen, was sie
hier eingerichtet haben?- Jetzt?
Irgendwann.
- Ich kann es schon jetzt erzählen.
Wir haben ja Zeit.
- Und es kostete fast nichts.
Gut, der Schreibtisch ist neu.
Etwas vom Wichtigsten ist ja
der Schreibtisch, das Arbeitsgerät.
Daher klärte ich mit meinem Mann ab,
was er für ein Bedürfnis hat.
Dann schauten wir, was ihm
am meisten zusagt, was ihm gefällt.
Ich denke,
es ist ziemlich schön geworden.
Die hier brachte ich von zu Hause
mit.- Ja, diese alten Bilder.
Die Sitzgruppe
stammt noch von Frau Metzler.- Ja.
Wir haben einfach
den Tisch ausgewechselt.
Er stammt aus dem Lagerhaus
des Bundeshauses.
Er ist antik und gebraucht,
aber sehr schön.
Wir bekommen noch einen Kaffee.
Ihr wollt bestimmt auch einen.
Kriegen die keinen?- Nein.
Nehmt ihr auch einen Kaffee?
Das hier ist frühmorgens
natürlich ein Aufsteller.
Und das hier auch.
Wenn ich
in diesem Papierberg arbeiten muss,
aufblicke und den hier sehe,
ist die Welt wieder in Ordnung.
Warum ist die Welt wieder in Ordnung?
Schauen Sie sich das doch an.
Hodler bildete das gut ab:
Es ist ein Ausdruck von Kraft,
Leben und Lebensfreude -
das Gegenteil von Papier.
Aber es ist auch ein Symbol des
Zusammenhackens, des Runterhackens.
Ja, für gewisse Dinge
braucht man halt eine Axt.
Diejenigen, die die Axt, die Kraft
immer ausklammern wollen,
haben keinen Sinn fürs Leben.
Das gehört auch zum Leben.
Schauen Sie,
hier ist die Kraft und die Axt
und hier Ankers Stillleben.
Es gibt beides.
Wer nur eines erträgt, ist gestört.
* Anschwellender,
spannungsvolle Klänge *
Christoph Blocher provoziert,
auch als Bundesrat.
Für böses Blut gesorgt
hat er bereits im Vorfeld
der gestrigen Abstimmungen,
als er sichtbar lustlos
die Einbürgerungsvorlagen
des Bundesrates präsentierte.
Hallo, Ueli.
Ah, hallo, Silvia.
Ah, da ist ja der Herr Bundesrat.
Hallo, Christoph.
- Hallo.
Tu nicht so freundlich,
du bist ja mein Gegner.
* Ueli Maurer lacht. *
Grüezi, Herr Leuthard.
- Herzlich willkommen.
Danke.
Ich muss dich noch etwas fragen:
Soll ich mich in die Runde
oder daneben setzen?
In die Runde?
- Ja, in die Runde.
(Sprecher) Die "Abstimmungs-Arena"
zu den beiden Einbürgerungsvorlagen.
Für die Vorlage tritt an:
Bundesrat und Justizminister
Christoph Blocher.
Gegen die Vorlage
kämpft SVP-Präsident Ueli Maurer.
Ist jemand integriert,
wenn er in der Familie
in einem anderen Kulturkreis lebt,
aber nicht bei uns
einen Zvieri essen kann?
Jetzt bin ich im Bundesrat
und es ist die Verpflichtung
der Bundesräte,
die vom Bundesrat beschlossenen
Vorlagen nicht mehr zu bekämpfen.
(Leuthard) Ist das für Sie
heute eine Pflicht?
Ja, natürlich, es ist eine Pflicht.
Das ist schon so.
So zerrissen wie in dieser "Arena"
sah man Sie selten.
Ich denke,
das halten Sie nicht lange durch.
Ich gebe zu,
dass das für mich eine Tortur ist.
Ich musste oft vors Volk treten
und Dinge vertreten,
die gegen
meine innerste Überzeugung waren.
Einem Politiker, der eine Meinung
und eine Richtung hat,
schnürt es beinahe die Kehle zu,
wenn er so vors Volk treten muss.
Die Einbürgerungsvorlage
scheitert im Jahr 2004 an der Urne.
Für die Befürworter ist klar:
Dass der persönliche Einsatz,
auch der eines Bundesrates,
durchaus ausschlaggebend
für das Resultat
einer Abstimmung sein kann.
Der nächste Konflikt:
Die Bilateralen II
mit dem sog. Schengen-Abkommen.
Der Gesamtbundesrat setzt sich unter
der Führung des Bundespräsidenten
für die Bilateralen II ein.
Mit "geschlossen" meine ich
das Kollegialitätsprinzip.
Die Abstimmung im Bundesrat
zum Schengen-Beitritt
war weder einstimmig,
noch steht der Bundesrat heute
geschlossen hinter diesem Projekt.
Alles andere ist wahrheitswidrig.
Also, ich habe noch grosse Hoffnung
in seine intellektuelle Entwicklung,
was Schengen betrifft.
Herr Couchepin hat
ein elitäres Demokratieverständnis.
Nach dem Flugzeugabsturz von
Überlingen mit über 40 toten Kindern
sagt Blocher
zu Verkehrsminister Leuenberger:
"Ich an deiner Stelle
würde zurücktreten."
Sie forderten Bundesrat Leuenberger
vor 14 Tagen zum Rücktritt auf.
Nein, nein.
Das liegt nicht in meiner Kompetenz.
Wir haben
die Problematik der Indiskretionen
schon mehrmals diskutiert.
Ich komme aus der Wirtschaft.
Für uns ist der Konflikt
bei der Entscheidungsfindung normal.
Wir pflegen ihn sogar.
Das war im Bundesrat nicht üblich.
Ich verlangte immer eine Abstimmung.
Ich sagte: "Hier drin muss doch
jeder Stellung nehmen können."
Sie meinten immer:
"Das tut man doch nicht."
Am Ende hiess es:
"Der Bundesrat hat beschlossen."
Wenn man sagte,
dass die Entscheidung Quatsch sei,
meinten alle:
"Die Mehrheit hat entschieden."
* Sanfte klassische Musik
im Hintergrund *
Man merkt ja, dass
die politische Landschaft aufbricht.
Sie sieht ein bisschen aus
wie ein Hühnerstall,
in den ein Fuchs eingefallen ist.
Alle Hühner flattern umher,
wissen nicht mehr wohin
und was sie tun sollen.
Das ist eigentlich ein guter Anfang.
Es kann nicht mehr so weitergehen.
Auch Frau Bundesrätin
sorgt für Wirbel.
Der Fotograf wünscht,
dass Sie hier sitzen.
Es wäre gut, wenn Sie
dort sitzen würden.- Ja, gut.
Steht es wirklich
so schlecht um die Schweiz?
Was müsste sich
im heutigen System ändern?
Oh, Sie fragen mich so direkt?
Ich habe natürlich
schon sehr viel nachgedacht.
Ich frage mich,
ob es sich die Schweiz leisten kann,
eine Regierung zu haben,
die nicht so tatkräftig ist,
wie sie sein könnte,
wenn sie homogener wäre.
(Mann) Eine bürgerliche Mehrheit?
- Beispielsweise.
Aber man könnte auch die SP, die CVP
oder die Grünen ins Auge fassen.
Dann wäre sie
sehr viel schlagkräftiger.
Meiner Meinung nach
haben wir das in der Schweiz nötig.
* Dunkle, spannungsvolle Klänge *
Ihre Aussage wurde aufgenommen
und es rumorte ziemlich stark.
Dann kam Ihr Mann wieder ins Spiel.
Kann man sagen,
dass es nach Drehbuch läuft?- Ja ...
Seit ich im Bundesrat bin,
diskutieren wir
natürlich oft über diese Frage.
Sie lancierte das,
ohne dass es auf dem Zeitplan stand.
Aber dass sie
diese Grundsatzfrage aufwarf,
steht wieder im Drehbuch.
* Fröhliche Volksmusik *
In meinem Umfeld
gibt es keinen anderen Menschen,
der mir so nahesteht.
Ich habe keinen engeren
Gesprächspartner als meine Frau.
Das liegt schon rein
an den äusserlichen Faktoren.
Wir leben zusammen, wir essen
zusammen, wir schlafen zusammen.
In der Freizeit sind wir zusammen.
Meine Frau ist
eine sehr gute Gesprächspartnerin.
Erstens ist sie klug -
das ist natürlich wichtig -,
zweitens ist sie sehr emotional -
das ist nicht so einfach -
und drittens nimmt sie sehr stark
an den Problemen teil, die ich habe.
Das ist natürlich wertvoll,
denn vieles kann ich ja
mit sonst niemandem besprechen.
Viele fragten mich,
ob ich das alles ohne meine Frau
auch hätte tun können.
Das weiss ich nicht,
aber mit einer Frau,
die keinen Anteil genommen hätte,
wäre es
sicher nicht möglich gewesen.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass mein Mann
ausserordentliche Fähigkeiten hat.
Er hat
eine sehr schnelle Auffassungsgabe -
das war mir bekannt.
Er wird sehr rasch wissen,
worum es geht.
Zudem ist er
sehr entscheidungsfreudig.
Er sieht die Dinge nicht nur,
sondern trifft danach
auch Entscheidungen.
Und er hat die Kraft, um es
durchzuziehen. Das ist auch wichtig.
Ich wusste,
dass er diese Fähigkeiten hat.
Daher denke ich, dass er
diesen Dienst wahrnehmen kann.
Das klingt, als hätte er
etwas von einem Übermenschen.
Ein ausserordentlicher Mensch.
* Sie lacht. *
Vielen Dank.
Sie hat nicht
bei jeder Auseinandersetzung
eine so hohe Meinung von mir.
Das lassen wir jetzt so stehen.
Die Blochers ahnen nicht,
dass die Bundesratskarriere
bald vorbei sein wird.
Und das hängt
mit seinem Politstil zusammen.
Ja, ja, er hat es gemerkt.
* Dunkle, unstete Klänge *
Rückblende in die 90er-Jahre:
Christoph Blocher,
damals Nationalrat,
verspottet
seine politischen Gegner regelmässig:
Jawohl.
Gestern musste ich im Fernsehen
in der "Arena" antreten -
mit meiner Freundin Frau Koch.
In der Industrie, in der Produktion
der kleinen und mittleren Betrieben
ruiniert man damit die Produktion.
Das tun Sie massiv und Sie ...
(Mann) Ja?- Nein ...
Sie sind einfach ein Flegel.
Frau Koch ...
Frau Koch, Sie bräuchten eigentlich
einen, aber ich war schön ruhig.
Sie bräuchten einen Knebel.
- Ihr Benehmen ist unglaublich.
Ich habe wirklich langsam
das Gefühl, sie sei meine Freundin.
Sie spricht immer von mir.
* Sanfte Alphornklänge *
Die Menschen
laufen nicht mir hinterher,
aber sie merkten, dass wir
eine gute politische Linie brauchen.
Aber Sie führen schon.
- Führen?
Nein, ich sage nur meine Meinung.
Ich sage, was ich denke. Wenn das
auffällt, kann ich nichts dafür.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Wir haben ihn blau gemacht
und etwas geschnürt,
damit diejenigen, die befürchteten,
dass der Stiefel
an Nazi-Zeiten erinnere ...
Solche Stiefel
hatten sie bestimmt nicht.
Ich hatte übrigens noch nie
eine so günstige Inseratekampagne.
* Der Journalist lacht auf. *
Nein, wirklich.
Das ist unglaublich.
Das Stiefel-Inserat war bereits
in der ganzen Schweiz verbreitet,
bevor wir es einmal gedruckt hatten.
Über all die Jahre
provoziert Blochers SVP
immer wieder
mit umstrittenen Kampagnen.
Das Plakat hier, das wir für
die Asyl-Initiative kreierten ...
Wissen Sie, weshalb sich alle
so über dieses Plakat empören?
Weil es stimmt.
Hier blickt ein Krimineller
durch die Schweizer Fahne hindurch.
Das wird damit wunderschön gezeigt.
Denken Sie nicht,
dass diese Leute der Stil stört.
Die Wahrheit stört sie.
* Jubel *
Manchmal muss man
gewisse Dinge polternd sagen.
Es kommt auf die Situation an.
Alles hat seine Zeit.
Ich mache das nicht so bewusst,
aber in einer Kampfsituation kann
man nicht das Gewehr streicheln,
sondern man muss schiessen.
Das ist im Krieg auch so.
Plakate über Ausländer
lösen heftige Diskussionen aus.
* Spannungsvolle, dunkle Klänge *
Begonnen hat der aggressive Politstil
1993 mit dem
sog. Messerstecher-Inserat.
Dass gewisse Leute verletzt sind,
sich durch dieses Inserat
getroffen fühlen,
liegt daran,
dass sehr viele Leute merken,
dass sie an dieser verfehlten
Entwicklung mitschuldig sind.
Die Diffamierung der Netten
und Linken
sei verantwortlich für die angeblich
zunehmende Kriminalität.
(Piller) Ich finde
dieses Inserat echt läppisch.
Aber wir dürfen
den Hintergrund nicht vergessen:
Das ist der Beginn einer Kampagne,
die wir uns in der Schweiz
nicht gewohnt sind.
Diese Politkultur
ist eine Schwarzweissmalerei.
Man baut ein Feindbild auf, grenzt
aus und sagt: "Ihr seid schuld."
Heute muss man die Dinge tatsächlich
mit einfachen Mitteln ausdrücken.
Damit beleidigt sie
einen politischen Gegner.
Wer Hass sät, wird Sturm ernten.
Deshalb können wir
in der direkten Demokratie
nicht so aufeinander losgehen.
Ich war schockiert und erschüttert.
Wenn man sich daran erinnert,
was in unserer Jugendzeit unter
dem Titel der Dolchstosslegende
im Ausland passierte ...
Diese Leute wurden zuerst
mit Vorwürfen überhäuft,
dann geistig ausgegrenzt
und letztlich physisch vernichtet.
Am Ende, als der ganze Spuk
vorbei war, hiess es:
"Das haben wir nicht gewollt."
Meiner Meinung nach
muss man solchen Anwandlungen
und Methoden von Anfang an
Paroli bieten und sagen:
"So geht es nicht."
Otto Stich kam wegen dieses Inserats
nicht an Ihre Albisgüetli-Tagung.
Wie sehen Sie das
Messerstecher-Inserat im Nachhinein?
Das war das beste Inserat,
das wir je gemacht haben.
Die Freisinnigen waren verletzt,
weil sie dachten,
mit den Netten seien sie gemeint -
was nicht mal stimmt.
Aber es gibt sicher auch viele
Freisinnige, die zu nett waren.
Sogar in unseren Reihen
gab es solche Leute.
Ich verstand nie,
weshalb das Inserat so schlimm war.
Das ist meine Überzeugung und
ich kann Sie Ihnen auch darlegen ...
Das klingt wunderbar, aber genau so
totalitär sind Sie innenpolitisch,
wenn Sie die Netten und die Linken
derart kriminalisieren.
Wollen wir darüber sprechen?
- Das ist dieselbe Mentalität.
So kommen wir nicht weiter.
Sprechen wir über die Linken und
die Netten. Was haben wir gesagt?
Nein, bitte nicht.
- Ja, ja, gut.
Also, wir lassen die Linken
und die Netten beiseite.
Das wäre ein interessantes Thema.
Wir machen es in einer
späteren Sendung zum Thema.
Es gab in den letzten 100 Jahren
nie eine Zeit,
in der die Schweiz
innerlich so bedroht war -
nicht von aussen, sondern von innen.
Daher müssen wir wieder mal zeigen,
dass wir zu diesem Land stehen.
Das müssen wir nicht
auf einer menschenleeren Wiese tun,
sondern auf der Bahnhofstrasse.
Die Trychler sind präsent
und machen viel Lärm.
Die Scheiben der Grossbanken
sollen ruhig klirren,
damit alle merken,
dass wir für die Schweiz sind.
* Besinnliche Klänge *
Der Trychler-Aufmarsch
in der Bahnhofstrasse von Zürich.
Warum sind Sie heute gekommen?
Das ist eine Selbstverständlichkeit.
Ich möchte
diese Bewegung unterstützen,
die meiner Meinung nach
in der Schweiz immer stärker wird.
Können Sie nicht
etwas zur Seite gehen?
Blochers Demonstration provoziert:
Es kommt
auf der anderen Seite der Limmat
zu Gegendemonstrationen
zwischen Links- und Rechtsextremen.
* Polizeisirene *
* Die Menge
skandiert unverständlich. *
Politisch Andersdenkende
auszugrenzen,
lächerlich zu machen,
als heimatmüde zu bezeichnen,
darf nicht zum Stil
der politischen Auseinandersetzung
in der Schweiz werden.
* Applaus *
Genau so wenig wie Gewalt.
* Jubel, Pfiffe *
Sie führten
einen polarisierenden Politstil ein,
den es zuvor noch nicht gab.
Ja, also ... Ich finde es gar nicht
schlimm, wenn jemand polarisiert.
Was bedeutet das eigentlich?
Jemand vertritt überzeugt
seine Meinung.
Wenn er diese vertritt, vertritt
jemand anderes das Gegenteil -
ebenso überzeugt.
Dann entstehen zwei Pole.
Wo fiel ich in der Schweiz
besonders mit Polarisierung auf?
Bei der Wahrung
der Unabhängigkeit der Schweiz.
Diesbezüglich kann man
nicht klar genug sein.
Das polarisiert, v.a.
wenn die ganze Classe politique,
wie es damals der Fall war,
in Richtung
Europäische Union marschiert
und die Unabhängigkeit
aufgeben will.
Dann braucht es doch jemanden,
der sagt,
was der Vorteil
von Selbstbestimmung ist.
Das müssen Sie sich
zuerst anschauen.
Dieser Stier
sieht sehr aggressiv aus.
Hat er etwas mit Ihnen zu tun?
- Den schenkte mir meine Frau.
Mit welchen Worten?
- Mir gefiel er immer.
Sie sagte, er passe gut zu mir.
Er sieht sehr aggressiv aus, nicht?
- Nein.
Doch, doch.
- Ja, aggressiv ... Nein.
Er drückt Kraft und Lebenswille aus.
Nein, nein, das ist ... Ja, ja.
Schauen Sie ihn sich mal an.
Das ist doch ein schönes Tier.
* Erwartungsvolle,
pulsierende Musik *
Laufen im Kanton Zürich,
in der Nähe des Rheinfalls.
Hier kommt Christoph Blocher
1940 auf die Welt.
Mein Vater war der Dorfpfarrer.
Wir waren elf Kinder.
Das sagt genug.
Aber wir mussten nie hungern.
Es sassen elf Kinder am Tisch.
Zusammen mit unseren Eltern
machte das 13 Personen.
Wenn unser Vater da war -
das war er in der Regel -
durften wir nicht sprechen,
ohne uns zu Wort zu melden.
Wir durften auch
nicht untereinander sprechen.
Ich schlief in den ersten Jahren
im grossen Kinderschlafzimmer.
Dort übernachteten
die sieben Jüngsten.
Das war natürlich
eine ziemlich bewegte Angelegenheit.
Wir mussten früh zu Bett -
um 19 Uhr.
Denn unsere Mutter
machte ja den Haushalt.
Sie stand morgens um 6 Uhr auf
und ging meist
erst gegen Mitternacht zu Bett.
Deshalb schickte sie uns
um 19 Uhr ins Bett.
Unsere Mutter
setzte sich jeden Abend -
auch nach der grössten Anstrengung -
auf einen Stuhl
und sprach ein kurzes Gebet.
Ich höre sie heute noch:
"Lieber Gott, wir danken dir für
alles, was du uns geschenkt hast."
Dann kam das Vaterunser
und danach sagte sie:
"Gib uns eine gute Nacht"
und ratterte die Namen
aller elf Kinder herunter:
"Martin, Judith, Gerhard, Sophie,
Therese, Miriam, Christoph,
Hedwig, Andreas, Brigitte, Gertrud".
Es ging also auch lustig zu und her.
Dann ging unsere Mutter. Wenn sie
weg war, standen wir leise auf.
Wenn wir sie auf der Treppe hörten,
gingen wir rasch wieder ins Bett.
Laufen bestand
nur aus dem Pfarrhaus,
der Kirche,
einem kleinen Bauernhof,
einem grösseren Bauernhof
und einem Schloss.
Deshalb waren
unsere Nachbarn Bauern.
Wenn man mich
zu Hause vor die Tür stellte,
ging ich immer zu unserem Nachbarn.
Dort gab es Tiere:
Pferde und Kühe.
Der Bauer nahm uns mit aufs Feld.
Das gefiel mir sehr.
Später kam ich in den Kanton Bern
in den Landdienst,
nach Kühlewil oberhalb von Bern.
Daraufhin beschloss ich,
Bauer zu werden.
Mein Vater riet mir davon ab.
Er hatte nicht unrecht.
Er sagte: "Du hast kein Gewerbe."
Ich antwortete:
"Dann muss ich halt Pächter werden
oder ich werde Bauernknecht."
Er meinte: "Tu was du willst,
aber es ist schwierig."
Dann machte ich eine Bauernlehre.
Später holt er die Matura nach
und studiert Recht.
Ich hatte eine ideale Jugend.
Sie fragten mich,
ob wir arm oder reich waren.
Auf keinen Fall reich - bescheiden.
Aber das merkten wir nicht,
und es störte uns nicht.
Und heute ist er
mehrfacher Milliardär.
So, nun gehen wir runter ins Museum.
Dies ist das Büro
und hier ist das Museum.
Meine Frau hat hier
schöne Kunsträume gestaltet.
Es ist ein wunderbares Kunstmuseum
geworden.
Hier sehen Sie einen Hodler,
hier einen Giacometti
bzw. mehrere Giacomettis,
auf dieser Seite
sehen Sie Albert Anker
und hier nochmals.
Dann gehen wir mal zu Albert Anker.
- Ja.
Schauen Sie sich
diese Farbenpracht an.
Das ist Anker.
Diese Farbenpracht und diese Kon-
stellation sind unglaublich schön.
Er sagt: "Schaut euch die Schönheit
des Menschen als solches an."
* Sanfte, verträumte Musik
übertönt Blochers Worte. *
In Tat und Wahrheit
war das eine triste Zeit.
Die Menschen hungerten teilweise.
Insbesondere die Arbeiter
lebten in düsteren Löchern.
Das sieht man bei Anker nicht.
Er malte
eine etwas idealisierte Welt.
Im Berner Seeland gab es damals
noch nicht viele Arbeiter
in düsteren Löchern.
Aber ich habe auch Bilder,
auf denen grosse Armseligkeit
und Düsterkeit zu sehen ist.
Sie zeigen jedoch, dass die Welt
trotzdem nicht verloren ist.
Sie sagten,
er würde die Armut verherrlichen.
Nein, Sie verherrlichen die Armut.
- Aha, ich.- Ja.
Es berührt einen doch richtig,
wie schön das Kind ist,
das hier schläft.
Es ist ein totaler Gegensatz.
Was der Mensch in
dieser armseligen Umgebung braucht,
ist Geborgenheit.
Das Kind
findet Geborgenheit auf dieser Bank.
Wer sich das anschaut,
sieht nicht
in erster Linie die Armut,
sondern ist begeistert
von der Geborgenheit dieses Kindes.
Ich möchte den Faden
beim Thema Armut etwas weiterspinnen:
In Afrika gibt es ja Menschen,
die total verarmt sind
und aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen
nach Europa flüchten.
Sie leiden fürchterlich
und viele sterben auf der Überfahrt.
Diese Menschen
haben ja keine Hoffnung mehr
und kommen deshalb hierher.
Doch, doch, sie müssen
dort bleiben und arbeiten.
Diejenigen, die wirklich
an Leib und Leben bedroht sind,
sodass es keine Hoffnung mehr gibt,
müssen und können wir aufnehmen.
Aber wir haben die Schwelle
sehr hoch angesetzt.
Es darf nicht interessanter sein,
bei uns nicht zu arbeiten,
als dort zu arbeiten.
Man sollte nicht denken,
es sei das Richtige,
einen Menschen, der
nichts zu essen hat oder arm ist,
aus seinem Land zu holen
und hier zu versorgen.
Der Chinese
ist diesbezüglich realistischer:
Er sagt immer:
"Gib einem Hungernden
nicht etwas zu essen,
gib ihm keinen Fisch,
sondern gib ihm die Angelrute."
* Sanfte, verträumte Musik *
* Vogelzwitschern *
(Silvia) Oh, hallo.
* Lachen *
Bist du auch gerade angekommen?
Wunderbar, nicht wahr? So schön.
Heute ist es schön hier, was?
- Ja.
Also, es gibt zwei Versionen:
die meiner Frau und die von mir.
Ich lernte sie im Schwimmbad kennen.
Ich sah sie auf dem Rasen liegen
und fand, dass sie
eine wunderschöne Frau ist.
Dann sorgte ich dafür,
dass ich mit ihr ins Gespräch kam.
Sie sagt,
sie habe mich im Zug kennengelernt.
Das stimmt.
Ich sprach im Zug mit ihr.
Sie sagt, es sei ein
hochinteressantes Gespräch gewesen,
weil ich direkt zuvor
das Theaterstück "Nathan der Weise"
gesehen hatte.
Das habe sie so gefesselt,
dass sie sich "Nathan der Weise"
auch angesehen habe.
Danach hätten wir
so gute Gespräche gehabt.
Sie sehen also,
es gibt eine hochgeistige Version
mit "Nathan der Weise" -
dies ist die Version meiner Frau -
und es gibt
eine eher menschliche Version,
in der es um die schöne Frau geht.
Im Schwimmbad scheiterten Sie also
und im Zug hatten Sie Glück?- Ja.
Ja, da kannten wir uns bereits.
Ich musste schon kämpfen,
bis ich meine Frau heiraten konnte.
Das lief nicht kampflos ab.
Es gab welche in Amt und Würde -
daran erinnere ich mich -
die einen Sportwagen hatten.
Ich dagegen hatte ein Militärvelo.
Unsere Waffen waren unterschiedlich.
Aber letztlich habe ich gewonnen.
* Spannungsvolle, dunkle Klänge *
Als wir heirateten, war
unsere Situation aussergewöhnlich.
Mein Mann war noch Student,
hatte keine Arbeitsstelle
und keine abgeschlossene Ausbildung,
ausser eine Bauernlehre.
Er sagt immer,
er sei gelernter Bauernknecht.
* Sanfte Streichermusik *
Meine Frau war Primarlehrerin
und füllte den Brotkorb.
Meine Frau arbeitete und mit
ihrem Lohn brachten wir uns durch.
Wir malten uns nicht so konkret aus,
wie unsere Zukunft sein wird.
Ich hätte auf jeden Fall nie damit
gerechnet, dass er Unternehmer wird.
Als er mit dem Jurastudium begann,
dachte er, er würde Richter werden.
Damit hätte ich gar nie gerechnet.
* Sanfte Streichermusik *
Es kommt anders, und zwar wegen der
EMS-CHEMIE, die zweite grosse Liebe.
Die EMS-CHEMIE, der grösste private
Arbeitgeber des Kantons Graubünden.
Heute führt seine Tochter Magdalena
das Unternehmen.
Willkommen. Bitte schön.
Die Ausstellung ist eröffnet.
Die Emser Werke. Werner Oswald
gründet das Chemiewerk im Jahr 1936.
Für den industriearmen Kanton
ist das Grossunternehmen zentral.
In den 50er-Jahren lanciert Oswald
Nylon-Kunstfasern, Grilon genannt.
* Fröhliche Jazzmusik *
(Originalton) Das Grilon ist
die einzige vollsynthetische Faser,
die vollständig in der Schweiz
hergestellt wird.
In diesem Augenblick
wird ein Schaufenster in Zürich
mit zauberhaftem Grilon-Gewebe
geschmückt.
In dieser Zeit besucht der junge
Gymnasiast Blocher das Unternehmen.
Als ich mich
auf dem zweiten Bildungsweg
an der Minerva
auf die Maturität vorbereitete,
fuhren wir in einer Chemiestunde
nach Domat/Ems.
Damals empfing uns
interessanterweise
der oberste Chef dieses
Unternehmens, Dr. Werner Oswald.
Anscheinend -
das erzählte mir der Chemielehrer -
fragte ihn Dr. Oswald,
was das für einer sei,
der Fragen zur Rohstoffchemie
gestellt habe.
Der Chemielehrer erzählte ihm,
dass ich die Matura
auf dem zweiten Bildungsweg mache,
ein mittelloser Student sei und
in Wald/ZH bei meinen Eltern wohne.
Daraufhin bot mir
Dr. Werner Oswald
ein Zimmer bei seiner Familie
in Horgen zur Miete an,
damit ich nicht immer
ins Zürcher Oberland fahren müsse.
Seine Kinder waren jünger als ich
und er meinte,
es wäre schön, wenn ich ihnen etwas
bei den Hausaufgaben helfen könnte.
Als ich an der Universität
zu studieren begann,
schlief der Kontakt zu ihm
etwas ein.
Ich wohnte nicht mehr bei ihm.
Oswalds Chemiewerke
rutschen jetzt in die Krise,
Grilon-Textilfasern
sind kein Verkaufsschlager mehr.
Bevor ich
mit der Doktorarbeit begann,
kam er wieder auf mich zu.
Er sagte, er wolle
gern wieder mal mit mir reden.
Er meinte:
"Hören Sie, Sie könnten halbtags
in meinem Unternehmen in Ems
im Rechtsdienst und halbtags
an Ihrer Dissertation arbeiten."
"Das ist kein Hindernis."
So trat ich in die Emser Werke ein,
wurde in relativ kurzer Zeit
Sekretär bei ihm
und dann Generalsekretär.
Dann blieb ich in Ems hängen.
Er wollte natürlich
einen Vertrauensmann,
weil er Aufgaben abgeben musste.
Ich merkte, dass es ihm schwerfiel,
Dinge abzugeben.
Er hatte das Unternehmen aufgebaut
und brachte nicht die Kraft auf,
Dinge abzugeben,
aber er merkte, dass er jemanden
braucht, dem er vertrauen kann.
Blocher beginnt,
das Unternehmen umzubauen.
Er merkt rasch, dass
basierend auf der Grilon-Technologie
neue Produkte möglich sind.
Ich traf Entscheidungen, für die
ich teils gar nicht kompetent war.
Ich stellte Produktionen ein,
weil ich merkte, dass der alte Chef,
der drei Herzinfarkte gehabt hatte -
ein toller Kerl,
der wirklich für dieses Unternehmen
durchs Feuer ging -,
nicht mehr die nötige Kraft hatte,
um unrentable Produktionen
einzustellen und Dinge zu erneuern.
Die neuen Produkte,
von Blocher lanciert, haben Erfolg.
In der Zeit der Umstellung
stirbt Werner Oswald.
Oswalds Kinder beschliessen,
das Unternehmen zu verkaufen.
Als EMS dem Untergang nahe war,
sagte ich:
"Verdammt,
diese Firma muss man retten."
Sie sollte von der amerikanischen
General Electric gekauft werden.
Diese wollte die Hälfte der Mit-
arbeitenden auf die Strasse stellen.
Ich sagte: "Das kommt nicht infrage.
Das schaffen wir selbst."
Das war wahrscheinlich
etwas unvernünftig.
Blocher,
inzwischen Vater von vier Kindern,
entscheidet sich,
das Unternehmen zu kaufen.
Mit meiner Frau hatte ich
natürlich grosse Diskussionen.
Sie sagte: "Wenn es schiefgeht,
wirst du es wahrscheinlich schaffen,
die Familie
über die Runden zu bringen."
"Aber wenn du stirbst,
wenn dir etwas passiert,
dann habe ich vier Kinder ...
... etwa 20 Mio. Schulden
und eine Firma, die Verlust macht."
"Was dann?"
Ich sagte: "Das ist das Risiko,
das ich tragen muss."
Sie meinte: "Du trägst es nicht,
ich muss es tragen."
Wir stritten lange,
bis in die Nacht hinein.
Für uns stand im Vordergrund, dass -
wenn ein Verkauf infrage kommt -
die Zukunft des Unternehmens
sicherzustellen ist.
Was ein Ausländer
damit gemacht hätte,
können wir nicht beurteilen.
Ich darf Ihnen sagen,
dass die Bankgesellschaft
ein gewichtiger bzw.
der gewichtigste Geldgeber ist.
Über die restlichen
finanziellen Verhältnisse
sowie über die Bedingungen
dieser Kredite
werden wir keine Auskunft erteilen.
Ich bitte Sie
um entsprechendes Verständnis.
Der Börsenwert des Unternehmens
laut Blocher damals: 125 Mio. Fr.
Heute weiss man: Die Bankgesellschaft
gewährt ihm einen 20-Mio.-Kredit.
Er muss als Sicherheit sein damaliges
Einfamilienhaus hinterlegen.
Blocher sagt, er habe mit dem Kredit
17 % des Aktienkapitals gekauft,
sog. Stimmrechtsaktien.
Und so habe er
über die Stimmenmehrheit verfügt.
Ein gutes Geschäft
aus heutiger Sicht.
Böse Zungen behaupten ja,
Sie hätten alles umgestellt,
bereits gewusst,
dass Sie erfolgreich sein würden
und die Firma günstig gekauft.
Ja, gut, es gibt viele Theorien.
Ich kaufte sie zu dem Preis,
zu dem sie auch
die General Electric gekauft hätte.
Die Verkäufer sagten, dass sie
zumindest denselben Preis wollen.
Diesen habe ich bezahlt.
Für mich war das extrem viel Geld.
Zu diesem Preis wollte sie sonst
auch niemand in der Schweiz kaufen.
An dem Abend, an dem ich sie gekauft
hatte, sagte ich zu meiner Frau:
"Vorwürfe wird es sowieso geben."
"Wenn es schiefgeht,
wird es einige geben, die sagen:
'Der grosskotzige Kerl
ohne Geld kauft eine Firma
und führt sie in den Abgrund.'"
"Wenn es gut geht, wird es heissen:
'Der Kerl hat sie sich
unter den Nagel gerissen.'"
"Ich hoffe, ich kriege
den zweiten Vorwurf zu hören."
So kam es auch.
In diesen Jahren beginnt auch
Blochers politische Blitzkarriere.
Zuerst Gemeindepolitiker,
dann Eintritt in die SVP,
kurz darauf schon
Zürcher Parteipräsident
und zwei Jahre später
bereits Nationalrat.
Die freie Wahl zwischen Militär-
dienst und zivilem Ersatzdienst
ist für unsere Armee unzumutbar.
Mein Gewissen kann das gegenüber
der Verteidigung unsere Landes
nicht verantworten.
Herr Blocher,
was machen Sie nach dem 26. November
mit den Leuten, die
dieser Initiative zugestimmt haben?
Sollen die wie in der DDR
ausgeschafft werden
oder werden die wie bisher
als Schweizer/-innen anerkannt?
Darüber müssten wir uns
mal unterhalten.
Helmut Hubacher,
in dieser Zeit Präsident
der Sozialdemokratischen Partei SP.
Er ist damals Blochers
grösster politischer Gegner.
Und der einzige
prominente SP-Politiker,
der mit SRF über Blocher sprach:
Blocher war Präsident
der stärksten Kantonalpartei
und man sah sofort,
dass ein Stratege ...
.. am Werk ist, kein Hinterbänkler.
Seit zehn Jahren
streiten wir im reichsten Land
über die Bundesfinanzen.
Anders kann ich es nicht ausdrücken.
Nichts als sparen -
abgesehen von den Militärausgaben.
Dazu standen wir, Herr Hubacher.
* Sie sprechen durcheinander. *
Zwei da drüben waren dagegen.
... um die Opposition zu markieren.
Das ist begreiflich.
Ich sagte: "Endlich wieder
ein bürgerlicher Gegner."
Er teilt aus und steckt ein.
Die Mimose
ist nicht seine Lieblingsblume.
Er jammert nicht,
wenn man ihn angreift.
Er braucht den politischen Kampf
wie ein Fisch das Wasser.
Das ist sein Element.
Daher ist es spannend,
mit ihm zu fighten.
Was mal daraus wird, konnten wir
damals noch nicht wissen.
Die SVP ist damals,
in den 70er-Jahren,
die kleinste Bundesratspartei.
Sie verliert laufend Sitze,
sie ist in der Krise.
Christoph Blocher beginnt,
die Partei umzubauen:
Als ich die Partei übernahm,
beschloss ich, sie
auf eine neue Grundlage zu stellen.
Es war ein bürgerlicher Einbruch
und die linke Seite
war der Gewinner.
Sich nach links zu öffnen,
hätte nichts gebracht.
Wir sind unglaubwürdig,
wenn wir uns nach links öffnen.
"Wollt ihr alle Bauern verärgern?
"Wollt ihr die ganze Basis ..."
Bauern-, Gewerbe- und Bürgerpartei
hiess unsere Partei ja ursprünglich.
Wir brauchten lange, um diese Linie
gesamtschweizerisch durchzusetzen.
Sie wurde
eigentlich nur durchgesetzt,
weil wir Zürcher
Wahlerfolge vorweisen konnten.
Der Schwangerschaftsabbruch
darf nicht
grundsätzlich legalisiert werden.
Wer eine Schwangerschaft abbricht,
vollstreckt ein Todesurteil,
das der Experte gefällt hat.
Besonders mit dem neuen Eherecht
ist bei der Scheidung
die Existenz des Familienbetriebes
stark gefährdet.
Dieses Gesetz sorgt
für zahlreiche Ungerechtigkeiten
und ich sage es nochmals:
Die schweizerische Familie
hat ein besseres Eherecht verdient.
Bei der Revision des Eherechts hatte
er eine sehr konservative Haltung.
Er bekämpfte
all die Verbesserungen für Frauen,
die das Eherecht enthielt.
Ich weiss noch, dass er damals
zwar nicht von fremden Richtern,
aber von Richtern im Ehebett sprach,
die er ablehnte.
Damals verlor er.
Das Eherecht wurde angenommen.
Ich glaube, damals schwor er sich,
dass ihm das
nie mehr passieren wird.
* Hohe, unstete Klänge *
# (Im Chor)
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la-la.
Anfang der 90er-Jahre:
Der Bundesrat verhandelt mit der EU
über den Europäischen
Wirtschaftsraum, kurz EWR genannt.
(Originalton) Das Bundeshaus hat
schon viele Kundgebungen gesehen,
eine solche wie heute aber noch nie.
20 Spitzenmanager
gingen für den EWR auf die Strasse.
Der Konzernchef als Demonstrant.
Die Chefs von ABB, Ascom und
Volksbank werben um EWR-Stimmen.
(Im Chor) Svizzera,
Europa, solidarietà!
(Mann) Aujourd'hui vous dites oui.
* Jubel *
Vous dites oui à la Suisse
qui veut bouger.
Oui, ja, tönt es
aus der Romandie zum EWR.
In der ländlichen Deutschschweiz
hingegen
ist der Beitritt heftig umstritten:
Herr Bundesrat, liebe Mitbürger,
ich muss es kurz machen:
Seid ihr mit Blindheit geschlagen?
Müssen wir ins Ausland, wo alle
bis zum Hals im Dreck stecken
und nicht wissen, wie sie
aus den Schulden rauskommen sollen?
Wir sind nicht die Insel der Seligen
zwischen Narvik und Rom.
Wir sollten nicht denken,
dass wir funktionieren können,
ohne mit dem Ausland
zusammenzuarbeiten.
Der Bundesrat
hat klare Vorstellungen,
wie er mit Europa
zusammenarbeiten will.
Er formuliert für die Verhandlungen
über den EWR-Vertrag
konkrete Mindestbedingungen.
Genannt Verhandlungsrichtlinien
des Bundesrates.
Die wichtigste Mindestbedingung:
Der Bundesrat
fordert ein sog. Opting-out.
Ein Vetorecht gegen Gesetze, die
die Schweiz nicht übernehmen will.
Deshalb ist Christoph Blocher
anfangs einverstanden:
Wir wehren uns nicht
gegen einen Beitritt
zum Europäischen Wirtschaftsraum,
sofern es ein volles Mitspracherecht
und ein Vetorecht gegen Regelungen
gibt, die wir übernehmen müssten.
Wir waren also
noch völlig im Einklang damit.
Die Verhandlungen leitet
Staatssekretär Franz Blankart.
Er soll das Opting-out,
das Vetorecht, durchsetzen.
Wenn wir eine Lösung erarbeiten
können, die beide Seiten befriedigt,
ist es gut.
Wenn sich zeigt, dass das nicht
möglich ist, lassen wir es bleiben.
Davon wird die Schweiz
nicht untergehen.
Die Schilderung,
wie es dort zu und herging,
erhielt ich nur durch Staatssekretär
Blankart, der dabei war.
Er schilderte mir,
wie abenteuerlich es zu und herging.
Die beiden Bundesräte Felber
und Delamuraz
fliegen nach Brüssel
zu Schlussverhandlungen.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Staatssekretär Franz Blankart,
inzwischen verstorben,
hat Jahre später den Ablauf des
Treffens in einer Notiz festgehalten.
Wussten Sie damals,
dass es ein solches Treffen gibt?
Ich wusste von dem Treffen.
Ich wusste auch,
dass es das Schlusstreffen ist.
Aber wir wussten nicht, ob die
Schweiz das Vetorecht durchkriegt.
"Streng vertraulich"
heisst es im Dokument,
das inzwischen
im Bundesarchiv frei zugänglich ist -
signiert von den Bundesräten
Felber und Delamuraz.
Eigentlich haben beide Bundesräte
laut Geheimpapier den klaren Auftrag,
das Opting-out, das Vetorecht,
durchzusetzen, selbst ...
* Dunkle, spannungsvolle Klänge *
Es gab ein Abendessen,
wo reichlich gegessen
und reichlich getrunken wurde.
Man wusste, dass Herr Delamuraz
und Herr Felber gern trinken -
nicht nur Wasser.
Nur die Minister waren anwesend.
Alle anderen
mussten draussen bleiben:
die Dolmetscher, die Mitarbeiter,
die Staatssekretäre -
u.a. der wichtigste Schweizer
Staatssekretär in dieser Sache,
Herr Blankart.
Herr Delamuraz und Herr Felber
hatten nicht den Mumm,
die Anwesenheit eines Übersetzers
zu verlangen.
(Originalton) Fast in Siegerpose
verliess Bundesrat Delamuraz
um 2 Uhr in der Früh
das EG-Zentrum in Brüssel.
Deux heures du matin.
(Originalton)
Die Verhandlungen um einen EWR
waren nicht abgebrochen worden
und die Schweiz war noch dabei.
Als sie rauskamen,
wusste er gar nicht,
dass das Vetorecht gefallen war.
Wahrscheinlich hatten es unsere
Bundesräte auch nicht gemerkt.
(Originalton) Insgesamt
machten die Schweizer Minister
hier in Brüssel wohl mehr
Zugeständnisse als geplant.
Bonne nuit.
Heute wissen wir: An diesem Essen
wird das Opting-out, das Vetorecht -
die Mindestbedingung der Schweiz -
gestrichen.
Die zwei Bundesräte
haben die rote Linie überschritten.
Es regt sich Widerstand
in der Regierung.
Bundesrat Villiger schreibt
in einem vertraulichen Bericht
an seine Kollegen:
Die Bundesratsmehrheit wählt einen
anderen Weg: ein EU-Beitrittsgesuch.
Dann könne die Schweiz
wenigstens mitgestalten, heisst es:
Ich wünsche Ihnen
einen guten Morgen,
einen Morgen, der sich über
einem völlig neuen Europa erhebt.
Diese neue Dynamik eines EWR, diese
Öffnung, diese sinnvolle Veränderung
durchlüftet auch unseren Geist
und unsere Institutionen.
(Originalton)
Schliesslich, um 4 Uhr früh,
liess Bundesrat Felber noch
eine mittlere Politbombe platzen:
Der Bundesrat
hat inzwischen entschieden,
diesen EWR
nur noch als Etappe anzusehen,
als Etappe mit dem Endziel
einer vollständigen Integration
der Schweiz in der EG.
Otto Fischer und ich sagten:
"Jetzt ist es wenigstens klar, was
sie wollen: Sie wollen in die EU."
"Der EWR ist der Vorhof."
Das war eine der grössten
Fehlleistungen des Bundesrats.
Wenn man der EU beitreten will,
tut man das nur einstimmig.
Sieben gegen null.
Es stand jedoch vier gegen drei.
Strategisch und taktisch gesehen
war es ein totaler Fehlentscheid,
zu diesem Zeitpunkt,
mit nur vier zu drei Stimmen,
ein EU-Beitrittsgesuch zu stellen.
Dann sagten wir: "Wir bekämpfen es."
Ah, ja.
* Applaus, Jubel, Pfiffe *
Dass das nicht einfach ist,
ist klar.
Das benötigt Kraft und Vitalität.
Deshalb bin ich
zwei- bis dreimal pro Woche hier.
Das Volk muss Nein sagen.
* Trycheln läuten. *
* Jubel, Pfiffe *
Heute sagen die Politiker,
der EWR sei nur die Verlobung.
Ich sage immer:
"Ich sah noch nie jemanden,
der sich verlobte, ohne die feste
Absicht zu haben, zu heiraten."
* Lachen, Jubel *
Man wusste,
dass die Wirtschaft dafür ist,
dass alle Parteien, die Medien -
das Fernsehen und das Radio -
dafür sind.
Alle waren dafür.
Da wir uns gegenüber
der grossen Masse, die dafür war,
kein Gehör verschaffen konnten,
entschieden wir, jeden Tag
mindestens einen Vortrag zu halten.
Wir wollten es
jedem Einzelnen sagen.
Da die Zeitungen immer
die gegenteilige Meinung vertraten,
mussten wir unsere
mündlich ausdrücken.
* Applaus *
Kürzlich sagte jemand zu mir:
"Hören Sie doch auf damit."
"Das ist doch ein Kampf
zwischen David und Goliath."
Darauf antwortete ich:
"Aber David hat gewonnen."
Das ist einer der Schlausten,
die es in Bern gibt.
Ja?
- Wir bräuchten noch mehr davon.
Dann wäre die Welt
wieder in Ordnung.
Ich bin gar keine Politikerin -
überhaupt nicht.
Es interessiert mich auch nicht.
Aber was er sagt, hat Hand und Fuss.
Ich halte ihn für einen Politiker,
der ehrlich ist
und dem man noch glauben kann.
Er bläst nicht ins gleiche Horn
wie die anderen sieben Vögel.
Er ist ...
... der Churchill der Schweiz.
Sie hatten bezüglich Ihrer Position
gewisse Selbstzweifel.
Ja, das war eine bittere Zeit.
Ich träumte immer,
ich stünde unter einem Berghang,
ein Bergsturz käme auf mich zu
und ich müsse den Bergsturz
ganz allein aufhalten.
Ich träumte immer wieder, ich müsse
diesen Bergsturz aufhalten.
Doch das konnte ich nicht allein.
Ich war zu schwach.
Danach erwachte ich schweissgebadet.
Manchmal dachte ich
damals natürlich ...
"Habe ich recht
oder übertreibe ich?"
"Habe ich mich verrannt?"
Das wäre ja möglich.
Aber morgens, wenn die Sonne
aufging, wusste ich wieder:
"Das muss ich machen.
Die anderen sehen das falsch."
Es ist eine
der emotionalsten Politkampagnen,
die die Schweiz je erlebt hat.
Der Bundesrat lädt Sie,
liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger,
deshalb einstimmig
und mit voller Überzeugung dazu ein,
dem EWR zuzustimmen.
Die Schweiz hat sich am Wochenende
für den Alleingang in Europa
entschieden.
Volk und Stände haben
das Abkommen über den EWR abgelehnt.
Das dürfte die am knappsten
gescheiterte Verfassungsvorlage
der Nachkriegszeit sein.
Erstaunlich bei dieser Abstimmung
ist auch
die sehr hohe Stimmbeteiligung:
78,3 %.
Das hat es seit 1947
nie mehr gegeben.
C'est un dimanche noire aussi
pour la jeunesse de ce pays
qui se trouve privée d'un projet.
Es ist eine Freude für mich,
dass das Schweizer Volk die Kraft
zu diesem Entscheid aufbrachte -
gegen das ganze politische
und wirtschaftliche Establishment
dieses Landes.
Wenn wir die Abstimmung
verloren hätten,
wären wir heute
in der Europäischen Union.
Er hat gewonnen.
Mit diesem Sieg "Einer gegen alle"
erhielt er politisch
natürlich eine grosse Bedeutung.
Als die Abstimmung vorbei war,
hatte ich ja ...
... einen Nervenzusammenbruch.
Daraufhin zog ich mich
drei Wochen lang zurück -
in die völlige Einsamkeit,
in ein Jagdhaus in Vorarlberg.
Man durfte mit dem Auto
nicht bis zur Hütte fahren
und bis zum nächsten Dorf
benötigte man zu Fuss 2 Std.
Ich war ganz allein dort hinten.
Auch meine Frau war nicht dabei.
Ich kochte allein, schlief allein
und ging jeden Tag
von 8 Uhr bis am Abend spazieren.
Danach kam ich
völlig gesundet wieder nach Hause.
* Dumpfer, spannungsvoller Klang *
Ich politisiere,
wie ich es für richtig halte.
Ich bin Präsident der Zürcher SVP,
der grössten Partei
im Kanton Zürich.
Wir politisieren so,
wie es richtig ist.
Unser Ziel ist nicht, eine kleinere,
sondern eine grössere Partei
zu werden.
Die Freisinnigen und die CVP
waren für einen EU-Beitritt.
Der rechte Flügel der CVP
und der rechte Flügel der FDP
liefen zu einem grossen Teil
zur SVP über.
Blocher kassierte.
Die SVP
übernahm den konservativen Flügel
beider bürgerlichen Parteien -
der FDP und der CVP -
und wurde dadurch von der kleinsten
zur stärksten Bundesratspartei.
Wir sind erstens
anders als die anderen
und zweitens besser als die anderen.
Das wollen wir auch sein.
Daher haben wir auch
überdurchschnittliche Erträge.
Generalversammlung der EMS-Chemie.
* Getragene Bläsermelodie *
Nationalrat Christoph Blocher
ist auch ein listiger Unternehmer.
Da EMS
dank des guten Geschäftsabschlusses
über hohe liquide Mittel verfügt,
schlägt Ihnen
der Verwaltungsrat vor,
dieses Jahr
das nominelle Aktienkapital
von 62 Mio.
auf 31 Mio. Fr. zu reduzieren.
Das, was Sie bekommen -
diese 50 Fr. pro Aktie -,
ist für Sie kein Kaptalgewinn.
Das ist für Sie auch kein Einkommen
und Sie müssen es nicht versteuern.
Wir müssen jedes Jahr
einen neuen Weg suchen.
Wenn wir etwas Interessantes haben,
versucht man in Bern,
unsere Pläne zu durchkreuzen.
Wir können es
in der Regel einmal durchführen,
weil wir ihnen
immer einen Schritt voraus sind.
Aber ein zweites Mal
klappt es meistens nicht mehr.
Für Blocher bedeutet das damals:
7 Mio. Fr.
steuerfreie Wertsteigerung.
* Inbrünstiger Operngesang *
Müssten Sie als Patriot
eigentlich nicht auch dafür sorgen,
dass der Staat
zu Steuereinnahmen kommt?
Jemand, der dafür sorgt, dass
ein Stimmbürger, der im Land lebt,
möglichst hohe Steuern
bezahlen muss, ist kein Patriot -
im Gegenteil.
Ein Patriot sollte dafür sorgen,
dass man
wenig Steuern bezahlen muss.
Es ist besser
für die Volkswirtschaft,
wenn der Einzelne im Staat
Geld ausgibt,
als wenn der Staat alles absahnt.
Wenn wir die Bilanz mit den
200 reichsten Schweizern betrachten,
stellen wir fest,
dass immer mehr von ihnen
wenig bis gar keine Steuern
bezahlen.
Wenn die Leute in der Schweiz heute
etwas aufregt, ist es die Tatsache,
dass diejenigen,
die viel haben und viel verdienen,
immer weniger Steuern bezahlen.
Die Dummen sind eigentlich
diejenigen mit einem Lohnausweis.
Herr Bodenmann, ich bin Unternehmer.
Ich persönlich versteuere ...
Ich habe keine Geheimnisse:
Ich habe ein steuerbares Einkommen
von 1 Mio. Das ist viel.
Mein Vermögen - dieses
besteht nur aus meinem Unternehmen -
wird auf ca. 1 Mrd. geschätzt.
Ich persönlich bezahle pro Jahr
6,7 Mio. Fr. Steuern.
Ich muss mich jedes Jahr
mit ca. 6 Mio. Fr. verschulden.
Das geht, wenn der Wert
des Unternehmens zunimmt.
Jetzt legen Sie
Ihre Zahlen auf den Tisch.
Ich lasse mir
nicht solche Dinge vorwerfen.
Wie ist das denn bei Ihnen? Sie
erbten ja viel Geld von Ihrem Vater.
Wenn ich so viel geerbt hätte,
hätte ich schon lange
ein Unternehmen gegründet.
Wie ist das jetzt bei Ihnen?
Ich habe
ein Einkommen von 170'000 Fr.
Ich bewege mich nicht
in Ihrer Dimension. Das ist richtig.
Ich bezahlte letztes Jahr
im Zusammenhang mit unserem Projekt
mehrere Hunderttausend Franken
an Stempel- und Grundstücksteuern.
Daher habe ich den Eindruck ...
- Und Ihr Vermögen?
Das ist ja massgebend.
- Mein Vater starb vor Kurzem.
Das Erbe ist noch nicht verteilt.
- Sie müssen noch nichts versteuern.
Nein. Das gibt es im Leben, dass ...
Aber Sie brauchen mir nichts
über wenige Steuern zu erzählen.
Wenn ich wie Sie katholisch wäre,
könnte ich mit meiner Kirchensteuer
den Bischoff bezahlen.
Wenn jemand wie Sie
1 Mrd. Fr. Vermögen hat ...
Ja. Das ist ein Unternehmen.
- Hören Sie mal zu.
Wenn jemand 1 Mrd. Vermögen hat,
haben wir
in der Schweiz zwei Probleme:
Erstens haben wir
keine Kapitalgewinnsteuer.
Das führt ...- Weil wir
eine Vermögenssteuersteuer haben.
Das führt in Ihrem Fall dazu,
dass Sie 1 Mrd. Vermögen
erwirtschaften konnten,
aber nur 1 Mio. versteuern.
D.h., ein Promille Ihres Einkommens.
Ja.
Sie sind eigentlich ein Beispiel
dafür, dass es wichtig wäre,
dass wir in der Schweiz
versuchen würden,
Kapitalgewinnsteuern einzuführen,
damit Vermögen wie das Ihre nicht
unter dem Radar durchschwimmen.
Danke für die erhellenden Auskünfte
über Ihre persönlichen Verhältnisse.
Ein bisschen lockerer,
ein bisschen selbstständig.
Legen Sie ihm doch die Hand
oder beide Hände auf die Schulter.
Genau.
- Ah, so?
Ein Hochzeitsfoto? Also, nein.
Wir sind bereits
seit 28 Jahren verheiratet.
Daumen hoch.
- So?
Schön zu mir blicken.
Super. Vielen Dank.- Gut.
Dort ist die EMS.
Damit machen wir unser Geschäft:
mit Schweizer Qualität.
Das ist wirklich so.
An dieser Stelle
möchte ich insbesondere
Nationalrat Herr Dr. Blocher
herzlich dafür danken,
dass er seit Langem ...
... unermüdliche Anstrengungen
zur Entwicklung
freundschaftlicher Beziehungen
zwischen China und der Schweiz
unternimmt.
Wenn wir in China bauen ...
Bei Ihnen gibt es viele Menschen.
Jawohl.
- Die suchen Arbeit. Wir sollten ...
Sehr billig.
- Ja, günstiger als hier.
Dort müssten wir
nicht so moderne Anlagen bauen,
aber wir bauen
trotzdem die modernsten.
Als ich ihn das letzte Mal sah,
sagte ich zu ihm:
"Sie sind mit den chinesischen
Kommunisten viel anständiger
als mit uns
Sozialdemokraten in der Schweiz."
Er sagte: "Das stimmt."
"Aber ihr steht mir näher."
Das war seine Ausrede.
Das Schloss Rhäzüns,
heute im Besitz der EMS-CHEMIE.
* Kirchenglocken
läuten in der Ferne. *
Von 1809 bis 1814
gehörte es Napoleon.
Oh.- Napoleon
hat es persönlich gekauft.
Guten Tag.
So, danke schön.
Man glaubt,
dass das Napoleons Stuhl war.
Aha.
- Das sagt man.
Ja, bitte, setzen Sie sich.
Nein, bitte, bitte. Ja, ja.
Setzen Sie sich nur.
So. Ein sehr schönes Bild,
nicht wahr?
Es ist widersprüchlich,
dass er als Kommunistenhasser
mit China Geschäfte macht.
Er ist nicht der Einzige.
Geschäft ist Geschäft.
Das kommt zuerst.
Das nehme ich Blocher
gar nicht übel.
Ich nehme ihm höchstens übel,
dass er in der Schweiz
die SP so schlecht behandelt,
wenn er mit den Chinesen
so gute Geschäfte macht.
Sie sagen, Sozialismus sei
verwerflich, eine falsche Ideologie.
Andererseits
waren Sie einer der Ersten,
der mit Sozialisten,
dem kommunistischen China,
Geschäfte betrieb.
Ist das kein Widerspruch?
- Nein.
Für mich sind politische Gegner
als Menschen keine Feinde.
Ich bin klar gegen den Sozialismus.
Der Sozialismus
hat auf der Welt viel zerstört -
wie der Nationalsozialismus auch.
Die wussten schon, warum sie hinten
das Wort Sozialismus anhängten.
Dabei bleibe ich.
Das ist eine
völlig verwerfliche Ideologie.
Der Nationalsozialismus.
Heute wissen wir:
Die EMS-CHEMIE setzte nach Kriegsende
auf nationalsozialistische Chemiker.
Doch kein Wort
über das dunkle Kapitel
in der Unternehmensgeschichte
der EMS-CHEMIE.
Werner Oswald engagierte damals
die Nazi-Chemiker.
Sie halfen ihm,
nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
neue Produkte zu entwickeln:
Grilon-Kunstfasern.
Eine nylonähnliche Faser,
ursprünglich erfunden im
nationalsozialistischen Deutschland.
Der wichtigste deutsche Chemiker:
Johann Giesen.
Während der Nazi-Zeit
war er Direktor des Methanolwerks
Auschwitz-Monowitz.
Tausende von Zwangsarbeitern
starben dort.
Giesen wird nach Kriegsende
Verwaltungsrat der Emser Werke.
Damals ist Blocher
noch nicht bei der EMS.
Doch das Buch, das die dunkle
Vergangenheit ausblendet,
hat er mitverantwortet:
EMS hat nie
etwas falsch dargestellt.
Wir massen der Sache
nicht dasselbe Gewicht bei.
Wenn man sich
die Firmengeschichte anschaut,
bemerkt man einige Dinge
erst später und denkt sich dann:
"Das ist seltsam.
"Das waren wohl ziemliche Halunken."
Aber deswegen ...
In der Industrie
sind wir uns einiges gewöhnt.
Wir arbeiten auch
mit Sündern zusammen.
* Spannungsvolle, dumpfe Klänge *
Herr und Frau Bundesrat:
Seit vier Jahren sitzt Christoph
Blocher jetzt in der Landesregierung.
Sein Politstil provoziert,
für die Konkordanz-Regierung
eine Dauerbelastung.
Ich nehme sie. Ich habe
keine Funktion, ich stehe nur da.
Wir auch.
* Er lacht. *
Einige wählten mich ja
in den Bundesrat -
das wusste ich von Anfang an -
weil sie mich
ins Gefängnis sperren wollten -
ins Bundeshaus.
Danach sagten sie:
"Er ist noch drin."
Ich weiss, dass ein Freisinniger
aus dem Kanton Genf sagte:
"Ich habe Blocher
in den Bundesrat gewählt,
damit er endlich
in einem Gefängnis eingesperrt ist
und nicht mehr frei
in der Bevölkerung politisiert."
"Jetzt ist er
seit einem halben Jahr drin
und nun ist der Kerl
schon Gefängnisdirektor."
Die Wiederwahl steht an.
Doch jetzt mehrt sich die Kritik:
Blocher sei ungeeignet
für ein Kollegium.
Und v.a:
Er habe seine Macht missbraucht,
einen Bankier vor
einer Justizuntersuchung geschützt.
Komplottvorwürfe werden laut.
Dann:
Der Verdacht löst sich in Luft auf.
Was wir in den letzten Wochen
erlebt haben,
war der konzertierte Versuch,
Bundesrat Christoph Blocher
aus dem Amt zu entfernen.
Das waren Angriffe,
die das Ziel hatten,
mich des Amtes zu entheben.
Das ist ...
Das ist einfach primitiv.
Die SVP schlägt zurück - mit einer
Kampagne "Geheimplan gegen Blocher".
Alle, die nicht
für Christoph Blocher sind,
sollen plötzlich
Teil eines Geheimkomplotts sein.
Meine Herren der SVP,
verschonen Sie uns doch
vor diesen
parteipolitischen Peinlichkeiten.
Die SVP vergiftet
die Schweizer Politik.
Ein Klima des Hasses
und der Intoleranz werden geschürt.
Unser Auftrag ist es,
den politischen Sonderfall Schweiz,
unser Erfolgsmodell,
gegen die Banalisierung,
gegen die Personifizierung, gegen
die Polarisierung zu verteidigen.
Treffender könnte
unsere Wahlaussage nicht sein:
"SVP wählen, Blocher stärken."
Es folgt eine millionenschwere
Wahlkampagne der SVP.
Und sie gewinnt
die Parlamentswahlen 2007 klar.
In diese Zeit fällt auch
ein umstrittener Fernsehauftritt
von Christoph Blochers Bruder
Gerhard:
Er muss den ganzen Sauladen ...
... unserer schweizerischen Politik
ausräumen.
Und du, Christoph ...
Das Einzige, was du hast ...
Wenn man sich das anschaut,
merkt man gleich, was es bedeutet:
Das heisst Nahkampf
und das heisst Blut.
Das Gefahrenpotenzial ist ...
Pass auf, die Kamera läuft schon.
- Ja, ich weiss.
Wie man mit zwei Personen spricht,
die ...
Das ist schwierig
mit meinem Hals ...
Wenn ich abgewählt werde, gibt es
erstmal einen riesigen Aufstand.
Herzlich willkommen in der "Arena"
zu den Bundesratswahlen.
Ist Bundesrat Blocher
schon so gut wie wiedergewählt?
Ich bin überzeugt,
dass Bundesrat Blocher gewählt wird
und es ist wichtig,
dass er wiedergewählt wird.
Die von Ihnen aus gesehen
einzige Chance,
Bundesrat Blocher abzuwählen,
wäre, sich auf
einen überparteilich akzeptierten,
linksliberalen Kandidaten -
vermutlich von der CVP - zu einigen.
Das ist richtig.
- Sprachen Sie schon mit der CVP?
Sollte es
eine solche Kandidatur geben,
werden wir natürlich
darüber diskutieren.
Doch heimlich hat die SP
bereits die Sprengkandidatur mit
Eveline Widmer-Schlumpf eingefädelt.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Eveline Widmer-Schlumpf,
eine Bündner SVP-Regierungsrätin,
in Bern kaum bekannt,
ohne Sitz im Nationalrat.
Bisher wurden diverse Namen genannt.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich alle wiederholen soll.
Widmer-Schlumpf?
- Madame Widmer-Schlumpf?
Das ist ein Name.
Herr Blocher, reicht es heute?
- Danke, es reicht auf jeden Fall.
* Mehrere lachen. *
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Was viele im Ratssaal nicht wissen:
Eveline Widmer-Schlumpf
ist zu dieser Zeit
bereits unterwegs im Zug nach Bern.
* Handyklingeln *
Gewählt ist mit 125 Stimmen ...
... Madame Widmer-Schlumpf.
* Jubel, Applaus *
* Eine Glocke läutet. *
(Aus dem Handy)
... Madame Widmer-Schlumpf.
* Jubel *
Ihre Rolle bei Blochers Abwahl
ist bis heute umstritten.
Es war natürlich
alles schon eingefädelt.
Sie sass ja bereits
im Zug nach Bern,
bevor die Wahlen
stattgefunden hatten.
In diesem Sinne
erkläre ich Annahme der Wahl.
* Jubel, Applaus *
Judas, Judas.
Herr Blocher, was sagen Sie?
- Macht Platz.
Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung.
Ich finde das hervorragend,
eine super Sache.
Ich bin total überrascht,
dass es geglückt ist.
Eveline Widmer-Schlumpf wird eine
ausgezeichnete Bundesrätin sein.
Das kann ich jetzt schon sagen.
Es sind also alle total überrascht?
Total ist zu viel gesagt,
aber ziemlich überrascht.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Vielen Dank.
(Mann) Das habt ihr gut gemacht.
- Vielen Dank.
Diese Abwahl hat Sie persönlich
bestimmt getroffen.
Ja, selbstverständlich, also ...
Wenn einen so etwas nicht trifft,
ist man ein Trottel
oder man nimmt das Amt nicht ernst.
Parlamente können zwar Leute
aus der Regierung entfernen,
aber nicht aus der Politik
und nicht aus dem politischen
Schaffen im Lande.
Wegen der Abwahl dachten sie
natürlich, die SVP sei erledigt.
Als sie mich
in den Bundesrat wählten,
dachten sie,
die SVP würde dadurch geschwächt.
Nachdem die SVP in den vier Jahren
noch stärker wurde, dachten sie:
"Jetzt schmeissen wir ihn raus,
damit sie wirklich geschwächt ist."
Aber das klappte nicht.
In seinem Wohnort Herrliberg
empfangen begeisterte Anhänger
den abgewählten Bundesrat:
* Trycheln läuten. *
(Mit heiserer Stimme)
* Lachen *
* Jubel *
(Heiser)
Die Leute sind sehr dankbar.
Sie finden es dreckig,
wie das Ganze abgelaufen ist.
Entschädigt Sie das für das,
was in Bern passierte?
Es entschädigt mich nicht.
Was dort ablief,
kann man nicht auslöschen.
Aber es zeigt mir,
für wen ich gearbeitet habe.
Das ermutigt mich, weiterzumachen.
Ich musste mich
wieder neu orientieren.
Diesbezüglich hatte ich
natürlich einen Vorteil.
Ich war ja
mein ganzes Leben lang Unternehmer.
Ich habe meine Unternehmen
zwar an meine Kinder übergeben -
als ich das Amt antrat,
musste ich mich ja zurückziehen ...
Nach zwei Jahren sah ich,
dass sie es gut machen.
Meine Unternehmen
sind heute in guten Händen.
Nach meiner Abwahl aus dem Bundesrat
gründete ich
wieder selbst ein Unternehmen.
Meine ursprünglichen Unternehmen
führen meine Kinder
und sie gehören ihnen auch.
* Spannungsvolle, dunkle Klänge *
(Durchsage) EMS Werk,
Halt auf Verlangen.
Frau Martullo.
- Alles im Griff?- Ja, ja.
Seit 2004 führt Tochter Magdalena
Martullo-Blocher die EMS-CHEMIE.
Kommt es nicht zum Abfüllen?
- Doch.
Ich bin nicht der langsame Typ,
ehrlich gesagt.
Das Unternehmen, das 1983
beim Erwerb durch Christoph Blocher
einen Börsenwert
von 125 Mio. Fr. hatte,
ist heute mehrere Milliarden wert.
Tochter Martullo
führt so selbstbewusst wie ihr Vater.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
welcome to the management seminar.
Can you tell me
the seven thinking steps? First ...
First ... The seven thinking steps,
can you tell me?
Muss ich das kurz zeigen oder was?
Wo ist das jetzt wieder?
Wo ist mein Leadership-Training?
Huh? The seven thinking steps?
Have you heard about that?
I have a problem to solve.
The first alternative that
I think of is usually ... What?
Schlafen Sie da vorn?
Show your task again, please.
Your task, the slide with the task,
please.
Mr Köppel?
Me?
- Ja, Mr Köppel. Nein, Mr Köppel.
He is waiting if anybody else
will answer instead of him
but it's still him.
Present it on the ...
- Ach ...
You're a dreamer, you dream, du.
Nein.
* Sanfte Melodie *
Geht es Ihnen gut?
- (Frau) Ja.
Besonders positiv
entwickelten sich die Geschäfte
in den asiatischen Absatzmärkten.
* Volkstümliches Lied *
Christoph Blocher ist inzwischen
als Nationalrat zurückgetreten.
Jetzt kandidiert seine Tochter,
als Zürcherin im Kanton Graubünden.
(Mann) Ah! 30 %.
(Laut) Was ist los?
* Jubel aus dem Hintergrund *
Was ist los?
- Hinten ist ein Haken.
Wir haben zwar
noch nicht alle Gemeinden, aber ...
Ein toller Schachzug.
Wie machen wir das?
Herzliche Gratulation, super.
He, das ist super.
Hei, jetzt ...
Jetzt geht's los.
- Jetzt geht's los.
Eine schöne Überraschung.
Wir haben gekämpft.
He, hallo.
- Gratulation.
Es hat sich gelohnt.
- Unglaublich.
Hei.
In die Mitte.
Ich habe Berührungsängste
mit der SP. - Oje.
Die Ära Blocher geht also weiter.
Ich schalte zu Gianluca Galgani,
der jetzt die frisch gewählte
Nationalrätin interviewt.
Man kannte mich im Kanton
als grösste Unternehmerin
natürlich bereits.
Ich ging sehr engagiert in den
Wahlkampf und war überall unterwegs.
Man konnte mich kennenlernen.
Frau Martullo, es hat geklappt.
- Sogar in Ems.
Hey, wir sind stärker als die CVP.
Super.
- Super.
Wie lassen sich Ihre Firma
und Bern vereinbaren?
Ich bereitete mich natürlich
bereits während meiner Kandidatur
auf diesen Fall vor.
Ich behalte
natürlich meine Funktion.
Mein Vater machte das 30 Jahre lang.
Das geht.
Zurück zum pensionierten Bundesrat.
13 Jahre lang verzichtete er
auf seine Bundesratsrente.
Dann, im Jahr 2020, will er sie doch.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Was war der Auslöser, dass Sie
im Jahr 2020 Ihre Rente wollten?
Ich kann
etwas Gescheiteres damit anfangen.
Ich habe ja bereits
Geld in Gemeinnütziges investiert.
Dieses Geld dem Bund,
diesen Politikern zu überlassen,
hat keinen Sinn.
Die 13 Jahre Rente
entsprechen 2,7 Mio. Fr.
Schliesslich erhält er 1,1 Mio.,
fünf Jahre statt 13 Jahre:
Es wurde auf fünf Jahre beschränkt
und ich erhielt nur die Hälfte.
Ich beschloss,
nicht vors Bundesgericht zu ziehen.
Nun bin ich
gegenüber dem Bund halt wohltätig.
Aber Sie haben ja genügend Geld,
oder?
Nein, ich habe kein Geld.
Ich habe Unternehmen,
das ist nicht dasselbe.
Wann hat man genügend Geld?
Auch wenn man
genügend Vermögen hat ...
... muss man dem Geld Sorge tragen.
Wie hoch ist
Ihre monatliche Rente zurzeit?
Das weiss ich nicht auswendig.
Die normale Rente
beträgt 80 % von ...
Im Jahr sind das ungefähr
200'000 bis 250'000 Fr., glaube ich.
Also pro Jahr.
Und ein Teil dieses Geldes
fliesst bestimmt auch
in Ihre politische Arbeit.
Ja, auch.
Parteien im Allgemeinen
habe ich nie unterstützt, nie.
Ich unterstützte nur einzelne
Aktionen, wie z.B. den EWR-Kampf.
Dort investierte ich sehr viel.
Auch andere Abstimmungen, die
mir fürs Land wichtig erschienen,
unterstützte ich.
Wie viel Geld fliesst dorthin?
- Das weiss ich auch nicht.
Ich will es auch nicht wissen.
- Oder wollen Sie es nicht sagen?
Wenn ich es wüsste,
würde ich es nicht sagen.
Warum nicht?
- Sie wissen doch warum.
Dann muss man sich rechtfertigen,
weshalb man eine Sache unterstützt
und eine andere nicht.
Nein. Das ...
Danach fragt auch niemand.
* Spannungsvolle, dunkle Klänge *
Ah, ja.
* Nachrichtenton *
War das Ihres?
- Ja, muss ich es ausschalten?
Ich schaue kurz, was es ist,
ob es etwas Dringendes ist.
Ah, es ist meine Frau.
Was schreibt sie?
"Sicherheitsgurte."- Sehr gut,
falls Sie nicht daran denken.
Perfekt.
- Sie hat Angst um mich.
Gut, also.
Christoph Blocher
gibt nach der Abwahl
zwar nach und nach alle Funktionen
ab, politisch aber bleibt er aktiv.
* Trycheln läuten. *
Aufmarsch in der Innerschweiz.
Christoph Blocher und seine Entourage
feiern.
Nach sieben Jahren
bricht der Bundesrat
die Verhandlungen mit der EU ab.
Das Rahmenabkommen ist gescheitert.
Wie es weitergeht, ist unklar.
Die Schweizer Europapolitik
ist blockiert.
* Getragene Melodie, Trycheln *
Guten Tag.
Hört man mich hier?
Ist das Mikrofon eingeschaltet?
(Mehrere) Ja!
- Super.
Warum sind wir heute zusammen-
gekommen? Warum versammeln wir uns?
Man sieht doch,
dass der Bundesrat am 26. Mai
eine Entscheidung traf,
die die Unabhängigkeit
und die Selbstbestimmung
unseres Landes verteidigt.
Wer sorgte dafür,
dass das Rahmenabkommen scheiterte?
Ohne uns wäre das nicht passiert.
* Vereinzelter Applaus *
Merkt ihr,
welche Bedeutung die SVP hat?
Ich hätte nie geglaubt,
dass es bereits
auf der Stufe des Bundesrats kippt.
Dass er über seinen Schatten
springen kann,
ist ein ganz grosser Lichtblick.
Es ist toll, dass der Bundesrat
das fertigbrachte.
Ich bereitete mich
auf die Volksabstimmung vor.
Beim EWR musste eine Volksabstimmung
durchgeführt werden.
Aber meine Genugtuung
ist nicht allzu gross.
Denn unsere Gegner machen weiter.
Sie hören nicht auf.
Sie werden alles tun,
um die Schweiz in die EU zu bringen.
Wir müssen unsere Freiheitsrechte
selbst bewachen.
Sie, unsere Trychler,
müssen Widerstand leisten.
Die Trychler sind die letzte
Verteidigungslinie der Schweiz.
* Jubel, Applaus *
Vorhin sagte ich
gerade zu jemandem -
da vorn steht er
mit seinem Wikingerbart -,
dass ihr häufiger
nach Bern kommen müsst.
Ihr müsst vor Frau Sommarugas
und Herrn Bersets Büro trycheln.
* Jubel *
(Mann) So gut.
- (Mann) Jawohl.
Ein Hoch also auf die Trychler.
* Jubel, Applaus *
Nach dem Sturm auf das Kapitol
in Washington im Jahr 2021
wird es etwas anders betrachtet,
wenn man einfache Parteimitglieder
dazu auffordert,
ein Gebäude zu stürmen.
Also, das ist ...
Davon kann keine Rede sein.
Das Trycheln vor einem Büro
kann man nicht mit dem Sturm
auf ein Haus vergleichen.
Aber es war eine Aufforderung,
quasi vor der Bürotür ...
Sie nehmen das jetzt ...
- Sie waren selbst Bundesrat.
Sie tun so, als hätte er gesagt:
"Brecht unten die Tür auf,
schlagt alles kurz und klein,
dringt ins Bundeshaus ein,
stellt euch vor die Tür
und hebt sie aus dem Sessel heraus."
Das ist alles Blödsinn.
Er sagte einfach,
man solle die Geister austreiben,
die gewisse Dinge getan haben.
Ich weiss nicht mehr,
welche Dinge er aufzählte.
Diejenigen in den geschlossenen
Abteilungen im Bundeshaus denken,
sie seien etwas Besseres.
Sie denken, sie könnten sich
am Land den Fuss abstreifen.
Denen müsst ihr mal sagen,
wo Barthel den Most holt
und wo die Schweiz
noch die Schweiz ist.
Also, ein Hoch auf die Trychler.
* Jubel, Applaus *
Männer und Frauen der Freiheit:
zur Sammlung!
Wir mahnen: "Passt auf."
"Hütet euch -
zwar nicht am Morgarten -,
aber hütet euch
vor den ewigen Schweiz-Gegnern,
die uns in die EU führen."
Der Kampf geht also weiter?
- Ja, eindeutig.
Es lebe die Schweiz!
# (Im Chor) Gott im hehren Vaterland,
# Gott, den Herrn,
im hehren Vaterland.
* Unverständlicher Ruf *
(Mann) Bravo.
* Anschwellende, getragene Musik *
* Trycheln läuten. *
Alles Gute.
- Auf Wiedersehen. Danke.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Manuela Waldner - 2023